hello again or is he not paying you on
account of how he tried to fix the thing
his own self and busted it even worse
and then said you not that I got any not
at all mr. Nandi treats us all right and
pays us well laws no so I can talk to
him of court I reckon she's got a little
bit of he's sort of this unfortunately
in my apartments kind of filling up
would you I'd appreciate that so much
maybe don't tell him I wanted you to ask
just that
Oh mr. Nandi is doing that thing where
he breathes throughs no he doesn't talk
much
but he's got this plus he's got great
late sorry
you look like a woman who I haven't seen
her in a few days
I hope it's working okay because no one
wait I see what's going on oh no that's
not it at all
don't get me wrong I'd like to give her
a dis but if I give her one I won't
hardly make a bit on account of no one
else having you sound pretty sure give
her a chance
okay I'll do it that's the spirit
between you and me captain I'm not sure
miss Celia knows him too well
[Music]
have you dug dispatching yet okay but
how did he say it did he sound excited
was he like
not to worry if I never buy enough ah
look at me going on I'm sure you got up
anyhow
[Applause]
[Music]